I'm pleased to announce that the two
governments and the political parties of
Northern Ireland have reached agreement
it is 18 years since the Good Friday
Agreement 10 years since polar opposite
parties shared Parlin Northern Ireland
but the relationship between the
Democratic unionists and shin fin has
gone up in smoke
a flawed renewable energy scheme had
cost taxpayers an estimated half a
billion times but the first minister
refused to step down during a public
inquiry so her coalition partner brought
down the devolved government good
afternoon in the last few moments the
deadline has passed for shin fain to
nominate a deputy first minister to
replace Martin McGuinness the Northern
Ireland secretary is expected to
announce an election must now be called
I'm hearing from sources at the Northern
Ireland office that an election is
likely to take place in Northern Ireland
on Thursday the second of March no one
should underestimate the challenge faced
to the political institutions here in
Northern Ireland and what is at stake
nine months after the last election
Northern Ireland goes to the polls on
Thursday parties will then have three
weeks to form a new power sharing
administration or risk a return to
direct drill from Westminster when they
needed help with peacemaking before they
find it 3,000 miles away on the other
side of the Atlantic if there's anyone
who might know how to fix Northern
Ireland's devolved government it's the
american architect the man who refused
to give up until he had brokered the
Good Friday Agreement so we've come to
New York to talk to him senator George
Mitchell says he knew they had more work
to do in Northern Ireland we recognized
at the time the agreement was reached
and I said on that very day that by
itself the agreement did not assure
peace
or prosperity or reconciliation it made
them possible so what I said at the time
is that it would take many years and
many difficult decisions by courageous
leaders in Northern Ireland to attain
those goals some have suggested that the
United Kingdom's decision to leave the
European Union could destroy the Good
Friday Agreement your thoughts about
that I believe that the European Union
was an important factor that led the
United Kingdom and Ireland to cooperate
in establishing a process that led to
the Good Friday Agreement and I think
the UK being out of the European Union
may reduce the prospects for further
cooperation Northern Ireland like
Scotland voted to remain in the EU
Republicans fear the return of a hard
Irish border when the UK leaves if ever
they needed devolved government its know
ahead of brexit negotiations but the DUP
leader says forcing parties into
mandatory coalition does not produce
stable government the fact that one
party was able to plunge us into all of
this election a totally unnecessary
election should fee and walking out of
the executive was able to trigger that
so we may need to look at the whole
system of government as to whether we
can do things differently in the future
Shin fans new leader in Northern Ireland
says it's too soon to consider voluntary
car sharing I think that you have to
realize that we are society compared to
conflict we can only be in government
and share par with people who are
absolutely wedded to the principles of
the Good Friday Agreement and who
absolutely have equality at the core of
everything they do other parties differ
on the best form of government but agree
on the need for reconciliation
if we keep electing two extreme parties
to parties that don't want to work
together they can't work together then
we're going to have problem after
problem after problem and we have to
take opportunities now you to vote for
the middle ground I think next time
there is a partnership in storm and
castle
see the part of the executive it has to
be between two parties who are there not
because the law says they have to share
but because they want to share I
actually think the form of devolution
that we have doesn't actually encourage
people to cooperate to work together and
conciliation ilysm in the very rigid
form that we have actually encourages
people to retreat into their trenches at
every election senator Mitchell says the
politicians themselves will know if it's
time for the new structure did you
envisage that the mandatory coalition
established on to the agreement might
one day become up voluntary coalition
I think everyone anticipated that these
arrangements were established to meet
the problems and the needs of that time
and as is true of every society and in
particular democratic societies changes
in circumstance require changes in
approach so it is a normal part of the
development of every society that over
time the institution should be reviewed
processing should be reviewed so long as
the way you do it is through peaceful
and democratic means at this integrated
college in County Tyrone Catholic and
Protestant students work together they
can't understand why their politicians
have not yet find a way to do so if we
are children and the young people of
Northern Ireland and we're in an
integrated school and we have people of
different religions and everything then
we can all work together and get on why
can't the leaders of Northern Ireland do
the exact same and work together as well
to make a better Northern Ireland for
people like us do you think politicians
really need to take a hard look at
themselves and learn to put others needs
before their own I feel like a lot of
time politicians act in what's best for
their party or best for them in terms of
staying in their position as opposed to
look at what the people need and what
the people want a small screen campaign
for more schools to integrate as one
backing from the big screen
Northern Ireland moves forward from
division who do we look to for a future
we can share our children so why
continue to educate them apart different
religions different backgrounds
different schools there is another way
and the man who's lauded for his
peacemaking skills says the politicians
will find another way the real heroes of
the Northern Ireland peace process with
a political leaders of Northern Ireland
and the people of Northern Ireland it is
they who made the crucial decisions not
me not the Prime Minister's it was those
directly involved it's fashionable in
all of our societies to criticise to
mean ridicule political leaders and
often they deserve it
but on that occasion men and women of
great courage rose to the occasion it
took a difficult decision and interest
the people they represented and that
really must never be forgotten it will
take a heroic effort but the suspension
of devolution would be the greatest
setback here in a decade so one man will
be watching the politicians from a
distance and willing them all
I'm an American and proud of it but a
very large part of my heart my emotions
and my mind will always be in Northern
Ireland
you